[Music]
thank you
Philip K Dick's novel The Man in the
High Castle is an alternate history in
which the Axis powers and that is Nazi
Germany Imperial Japan the Italian State
and a few other minor Allies won World
War II against first the Allies or
rather they weren't even really that
Allied at the time the British Empire
the French of course and the Soviet
Union the United States stayed neutral
and then was later itself conquered in
significant part by these and so the
entire world has been you know you could
say divvied up divided among these
Powers whoever could take things did and
so we have
um you know these three main things uh
Nazi Germany and its Legacy it's the
most powerful state 8 in the world
followed closely by the Japanese empire
and then we have the much weaker and
it's not quite clear what's going on
with them Italian state which has been
given some of The Spoils of War and then
we have a few neutral countries Sweden
gets mentioned very early on Canada
appears to be neutral part of what used
to be the United States of America is
also neutral as well and so that is the
setting for this and it is at least for
us at this point definitely an alternate
history because the events are taking
place several decades after the you know
conquest and division of the the world
so the plot the characters and the
action are occurring in portions of what
used to be the United States
specifically the Pacific States of
America so the west coast and then what
are called the Rocky Mountain States and
you know we don't actually know all that
well exactly where the boundaries lie
for these things people have generated a
lot of maps but there is no official map
for Philip K Dick's book but the action
in this in a larger sense has a world
scope because what we're seeing
happening as all of these these you know
subplots are coming together is that the
Nazi leadership is going to be changing
hands and the Rivalry between the Nazi
State and the Japanese state is is
coming to an important head so we've got
these essentially two rival you know the
in the case of the Nazi State
totalitarian in the case of the Japanese
State semi-totalitarian Empires that are
going to be clashing with each other and
then many individuals sort of figuring
out their own role within this so we
should talk first about the Japanese
empire the larger co-prosperity sphere
and the Pacific States of America and
there's a few characters Through The
Eyes of which and thoughts of which we
can learn quite a bit about this the
first is Frank Frank formerly Frank Fink
who had been born on the east coast in
New York drafted into the army of the
United States of America
he had been sent to the West Coast when
the war ended there he was on the
Japanese side of the settlement line
there he was today 15 years later we
find out that on capitulation day he had
gone berserk hating the Japs as he did
and you notice we're going to be using a
lot of this old-fashioned racist
language it's in part because we're in a
racist world a world in which racism uh
in in the form of both of these massive
Empires has essentially taken root and
you know the America of the time
continues that as well anyway Frank had
buried his service weapons for the day
he and his buddies arose but uh
interestingly uh his mindset has changed
he you know recalls there Mr amuro who
had taken over a lot of rental property
in downtown San Francisco he was a
gouger a slumlord and what happened to
him well the Japanese trade missions had
cut off his head for profiteering and it
goes on nowadays such a violation of the
harsh rigid but just Japanese civil law
was unheard of it was a credit to the
incorruptibility of the occupation
officials especially those who those who
would come in after the war cabinet had
fallen and so you know what we see here
is that it's not just brutal force
ruling over everybody rather it's you
know very firm but fair and we also see
something interesting in this
this radio broadcast that Frank is
listening to
um
he uh is talking about uh an effort
right and
um they're they're thinking about
Germans walking around on the moon and
then the radio goes on
co-prosperity civilization and you
notice the co-prosperity sphere is now a
civilization must pause and consider
whether in our quest to provide a
balanced Equity of mutual duties and
responsibilities coupled with your
remunerations typical jargon from the
ruling hierarchy Frank noted we have not
failed to perceive the future arena in
which the Affairs of man will be acted
out namely out in space but then it goes
on and says we must consider with pride
however our emphasis on the fundamental
physical needs of peoples of all Place
their sub-spiritual aspirations which
must be and what are they talking about
there so sub-spiritual aspirations basic
needs of human beings now this is still
a very structured racial hierarchy with
Japanese at the top and Chinese being
treated essentially as slaves right uh
white people somewhere in between the
the Japanese not caring much about
what's happened to to black people in
the Americas
um but there is still this extension of
concern not in a human rights way but in
a way that's influenced you could say by
a sort of pervasive
um you know Confucianism something like
that thinking about taking care of
everybody feeding everybody for example
so that's an interesting intro to this
we also find out that not only are the
Japanese behind on the space exploration
game but when we look at what Mr tagomi
who is an incredibly important character
um
is going to bring up it turns out that
uh the the Japanese are kind of behind
on a number of different matters right
so how does this play itself out here we
go
um
for years the Pacific had been trying to
get basic assistance for in the
synthetics field from the Reich the
Germans the big German chemical cartels
IG farben in particular it harbored
their patents had in fact created a
world Monopoly in Plastics especially in
the development of the polyesters by
this means Reich trade it kept an edge
over Pacific trade and in technology the
Reich was at least 10 years ahead
the interplanetary Rockets leaving
festoon Europa consisted mainly of heat
resistant Plastics very light in weight
so hard they survived even major meteor
impact the Pacific had nothing of this
sort natural fibers such as wood were
still being used and of course the
ubiquitous pot Metals Mr tagomi cringed
as he thought about it he'd seen a Trade
Fair some of the advanced German work
including an all synthetic automobile
and so this guy from Sweden Mr Baines
who is going to be talking about new
injection molds is perhaps offering
something of course he turns out to be a
spy as we're going to talk about but so
what we have is a Japanese empire that
is being depicted as in many respects uh
you know becoming more and more Humane
not only in its official policy but also
in the approaches of its main in
characters that we see the Japanese
characters in this but it's
to some degree not just less powerful
but behind the Nazi German regime so now
we should look at the Greater German
Reich and none of the action is well
actually just a little bit of the action
at the very end is taking place in the
Reich but
um much of it is is determined by the
Reich and the Reich is more powerful
but it's also more malignant the Nazis
have not become more Humane over time if
anything they've become a bit worse and
what we're going to see is a very
interesting observation that the
Nazi regime and its members seem to to
not be able to keep biting off more than
they can chew right they have to go on
and take more and more things so there's
this great discussion that's happening
here now the Nazis appear to be stronger
but perhaps are not so
um here's here's a discussion that's
taking place as uh by the Japanese as
the German government is transitioning
by means of like something almost like a
covert Civil War
um the home Islands take the view that
the ger that Germany's scheme to reduce
the populations of Europe and Northern
Asia to the status of slaves plus
murdering all intellectuals Bourgeois
elements patriotic Youth and whatnot has
been an economic catastrophe only the
formidable technological achievements of
the German Science and Industry have
saved them Miracle weapons so to speak
it is a sleight of hand business the
non-ferrous auras man said mainly their
uses of atomic energy have kept things
together and the diversion of their
circus like rocket travel to Mars and
Venus he pointed out that for all their
thrilling Imports such traffic have
yielded nothing of economic worth
but they are dramatic Mr tagumi said his
prognosis was gloomy he goes on he feels
that most high-placed Nazis are refusing
to face facts Visa of either economic
plight by doing so they accelerate their
tendency towards greater tour de force
Adventures less predictability less
stability in general the cycle of manic
enthusiasm then fear then parte
Solutions of a desperate type well the
point he got across was that all of this
tends to bring out the most
irresponsible and Reckless aspirants to
the top and they're talking about the
German succession but this could apply
to the entire regime going back we to
Frank's you know Soliloquy and thinking
about the radio broadcast we find some
of the things that the German state has
done these Great Adventures some of
which have paid off some of which have
not so for example and we know that this
would not actually be possible in
reality would actually lead to all sorts
of problems
in this alternate history they closed
off the Mediterranean Sea and that
actually turned out you know okay for
them they have this project farmland and
they you know generated a whole bunch of
new places that could be farmed Ravens
laban's realm as you know Hitler had
called this in talking about the East
and they've also engaged in genocides in
Europe and in
um Asia and even worse in Africa and we
first hear about this in you know
Frank's thinking about things so
here's several passages
while the Germans were busy
bustling enormous robot construction
systems across space the Japs were still
burning off the jungles in the interior
of Brazil and he goes on thinking about
how um you know back in the old quaint
history book days the Germans had missed
out while the rest of Europe put the
final touches on their colonial empires
they were not going to be the last this
time they'd learned then he thought
about Africa and the Nazi experiment
there and his blood stopped in his veins
hesitated at last went on that huge
empty ruin and he thought Africa for the
ghosts of dead tribes wiped out to make
a land of of what who knew perhaps even
the master architects in Berlin did not
know a bunch of automatons building and
toiling Away building grinding down
ogres out of a paleontology exhibit at
their task of making a cup from an
enemy's skull the whole family
industriously scooping out the contents
the raw brains first to eat and goes on
it horrified him this gigantic ancient
cannibal near man flourishing now ruling
the world once more
we spent a million years escaping him
and now he's back not merely as the
adversary but the master and what do we
find out about what happened in Africa
well Robert uh children
who's much more uh
pro-nazi in many respects a Nazi admirer
is thinking about these things and he
says to himself
one had to blame the Germans for the
situation
tendency to bite off more than they
could chew after all they barely managed
to win the war and then they went on to
conquer the solar system while at home
they passed edicts well at least the
idea was good so you can see that
Sheldon is actually in sympathy with
this uh after all they'd been successful
with the Jews and Gypsies and the Bible
students and the Slavs had been rolled
back 2 000 years worth to their
Heartland in Asia out of Europe entirely
to everybody's relief back to writing
Yaks and hunting with Beau and arrow to
those great glossy magazines printed in
Munich and circulated around all the
libraries and newsstands you can see the
full color pictures for oneself the
blue-eyed blonde-haired Aryan settlers
who now industriously tilled called
plowed and so forth in the vast grain
bowl of the world the Ukraine those
fellows certainly looked happy and their
farms and Cottages were clean you didn't
see pictures of drunken dull-witted
poles anymore slouched on sagging
porches or Hawking a few sickly turnips
at the College Market all a thing of the
past like rutted dirt roads that once
turned to slop in the rainy season
bogging down the carts and so you can
see children is actually quite
sympathetic to this notion of you know
the better races are now in there right
but then he he goes on but Africa they
had simply let their enthusiasm get the
better of them there and you had to
admire that though more thoughtful
advice would have cautioned them to
perhaps Let it wait a bit until for
instance project Farmland had been
completed there the Nazis had shown
genius the artist and them had truly uh
emerged we've already talked about that
Africa had almost been successful but in
a project of that sort almost was an
ominous word to begin to hear
rosenberg's well-known powerful pamphlet
issued in 1958 the word had first shown
up then as to the final solution of the
African problem we have almost achieved
our objectives unfortunately however
and he goes on still it had taken 200
years to dispose of the American
Aborigines and Germany had almost done
it in Africa in 15 years so no criticism
was legitimately in order so you notice
that children is you know saying well
the main problem with it is it wasn't
completely successful this genocide
destroying almost all of the Native
inhabitants in Africa they are engaging
in colonization of the solar system
primarily the moon and Mars sending
these Rockets also Venus right but
notice what else children himself is
going to say about this
um
the flights to Mars had distracted World
attention from the difficulty in Africa
so it all came back to what he had told
his fellow store owners what the Nazis
have which we lack is nobility admire
them for their love of work or their
efficiency but it's a dream that stirs
one right and so this is uh quite
interesting we have this fascination
with big big projects that are horrible
in their effects and in what they they
do we also find out that the German
greater Reich is intending an attack on
the Japanese home Island which we'll
talk about in much more detail later
things are coming to a head they've been
planning for operation dandelion to
instigate some some fighting and start
essentially a new world war in which
Germany will be triumphant I do want to
bring up two other passages about uh the
Reich but they both in part also bear
upon the the
remnants of the United States of America
so we get the character Joe who is uh
going to turn out to be a an assassin
but is presenting himself as just a
Italian ex-soldier and truck driver and
he talks about the cultural decline of
all the places that are occupied by nasu
Germany so he says
is talking about
um music and he says I like Verity and
Puccini all we get in New York is heavy
German bombastic Wagner and ORF we have
to go every week to one of those corny
U.S Nazi party dramatic spectacles at
Madison Square Garden with the flags and
drums and trumpets and the flickering
flame history of the gothic tribes and
other educational crap chanted instead
of spoken so as to be called Art did you
ever see New York before the war yeah
she said trying to read didn't they have
swell theater in those days that's what
I heard now it's the same as the movie
industry it's all a cartel in Berlin in
the 13 years I've been in New York not
one good new musical or play ever opened
and it's the same with the book business
Joe said it's all a cartel operating out
of Munich all they do in New York is
print just big printing presses but
before the war New York was the center
of the world's publishing industry or so
they say right we also find an
interesting conversation being had
between
several different
minor characters about
what the camps are like where people
have to serve here we go
um
this is
there's a lot of reflection on on the
book that we're going to talk about but
Rita says that she had been in these
these camps Windham Mastin said you know
who who did a really good job in the USA
Albert spare not Rommel in the
organizational tote spare was the best
appointment the party made in North
America he got all these businesses and
corporations and factories going again
and on an efficient basis and Rita said
I couldn't live in those work camps
those dorms they have back East A
girlfriend of mine she lived there they
censored her mail she couldn't tell me
about it until she moved back out here
again they had to get up at 6 30 in the
morning to band music
and then went to Mastin says well you'd
get used to it you'd have clean quarters
adequate food Recreation medical care
provided what else do you want egg in
your beer and so again we see these
interesting comparisons the greater
Reich is very powerful in some respects
efficient in other respects quite not
beset by conflicts and a kind of you
know turning into a cultural Wasteland
then we get America itself America has
been divided up into four different
quadrants we have the Rocky Mountain
States there's border land between the
Pacific States of America and the Nazis
satellites that we're going to see
reference and the rocky mountain states
are a place of freedom but also to some
extent poverty they don't have much of
their own militarily they certainly
can't compete against either of these
and we see an interesting discussion
happening early on in the Rocky Mountain
States with Juliana
who's one of the other main characters
um talking with with Joe she says
if you're not happy in the U.S why don't
you cross over permanently I've been
living in the Rockies for a long time
and it isn't so bad I lived on the coast
in San Francisco they have the skin
thing there too everywhere you go people
are going to be placing you on racial
hierarchies and he says Lady it's bad
enough to have to spend one day or one
night in a town like this live here
Christ if I could get any other kind of
job and not have to be on the road
eating my meals in places like that the
older truck driver said to him Joe
you're a snob and then Julianna says you
know you could live in Denver it's nicer
up there
I and then she thinks I know you East
Americans you like the big time dreaming
your big schemes this is just the sticks
to you the Rockies nothing has happened
here since before the war retired old
people Farmers the stupid slow poor and
all the smart boys are flocked East to
New York across the border legally or
illegally because that's where the money
is the big industrial money the
expansion German investment has done a
lot it didn't take long for them to
build the U.S back up
and then the fry cook says something
quite interesting buddy I'm not a Jew
lover but I've seen some of the Jew
refugees fleeing your U.S in 49 and you
can have your U.S if there's a lot of
building back there and a lot of loose
easy money it's because they stole it
from those Jews when they kicked them
out of New York that goddamn Nazi
Nuremberg law I lived in Boston when I
was a kid and I got no special use for
Jews but I never thought I'd see that
Nazi racial log at passed in the U.S
even if we did lose the war I'm
surprised you aren't in the U.S armed
forces getting ready to invade some
little South American Republic as a
front for the Germans and they almost
get into a fight there but it shows you
some of the uh some of the we could say
perspective of what's going on we also
do have uh Nazi satellites the United
States of America has been mentioned
this is essentially the North and it's
been re-industrialized we also hear
about the south and we find out that
slavery of black people has been
reenacted in the American South we don't
really know too much about it we also
find out that Canada in some respect is
free Bob Hope is up there making fun of
Nazi ideologues such as gerbils we're
not sure how that's the case it's not
really explained here and then we have
the Japanese satellite states of the
Pacific States of America so there you
have it this is the setting for this
wonderful alternate history novel of
Philip K dick the man in the High Castle